[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo da sind wir wieder mit Tatort
Deutschland dem täglichen Podcast mein
Name ist Mirko Kasimir und an meiner
Seite ist heute Stefan Netzeband
ausnahmsweise unsere beiden krimi-ladys
Natalie und Toni sind verhindert ich
glaube heute wird das hier ganz schön
hart für unsere Hörer und für uns wir
haben uns nämlich einen Fall vorgenommen
der als Pokémon Mord Schlagzeilen
gemacht hat das klingt vielleicht
erstmal niedlich aber ehrlich echt im
Gegenteil die Täter hier die bringen das
kaputteste was man sich vorstellen kann
bei diesem schlimmen Fall hat Bild nicht
nur berichtet sondern war auch Teil der
Ermittlungen und deshalb haben wir vor
dieser Aufnahme länger mit bildchef
Reporter Frank Schneider gesprochen der
hier ausführlich zu Wort kommen wird und
wir müssen hier eine trägerwarnung
loswerden in diesem Fall ist ein Mensch
unter äußerst verstörenden Umständen
ermordet worden wer empfindlich ist
sollte sich diese podcast-ausgabe
schenken wir begeben uns in das Jahr
2001 und in den Duisburger Stadtteil
Homberg hier links des Rheins gibt es
viel Grün etliche Reihenhäuser aber auch
Sozialbauten mit vielen geschossen und
hier wird am 10 Januar eine
unvollständige Kinderleiche gefunden die
Nachricht erreicht auch Bild
polizei-reporter Frank Schneider der
sich sofort mit einem Kollegen auf den
Weg macht er bekam damals die
Informationen von der Polizei das
offenbar eine Leiche in einem Koffer
gefunden worden sei vermutlich aber nur
der Torso der Kopf fehlen noch und das
war mitten in Duisburg mit der
männlichen Tag wir sind hingefahren der
Fotograf und ich und als er eintrafen am
Tatort oder an dem Fundort dieses Tores
da war die Polizei auch gerade erst
dabei sozusagen den Einsatz hoch zu
fahren die Mordkommission war noch nicht
vor Ort die Spurensicherung noch nicht
und es dauert dann in der Regel ein zwei
Stunden zu diesem Zeitpunkt sicherte
auch schon durch dass ich auf morgen ein
Kind handelt und Kinder werden ja zum
Glück sehr schnell vermisst und dann
habe ich gedacht ich gehe mal in dem
Viertel rum und frage mal vielleicht ist
es sogar hier aus der Gegend weil es
eben an einem Altkleidercontainer lag
den man eigentlich nicht so findet und
dann bin ich durch dieses Wohnviertel
gegangen und habe dann wirklich nach
drei vier Minuten schon an einem ja so
eine Masten von einem von der Lampe habe
ich dann ein Plakat gesehen also
ausgedruckt ist DIN A4 Blatt vermisst
wird der kleine Sedat und dann ein Foto
des Jungen und das hat mich natürlich
sofort total erschrocken weil ich
gedacht oh Gott hoffentlich ist das
nicht das Kind und dann stand auch sogar
wo er zuletzt Leben gesehen worden ist
nämlich auf einem Spielplatz mich zu
diesem Spielplatz gegangen und unter
seine Mutter mit einem Kind und auf der
Bank und dann habe ich die Frau
angesprochen gefragt haben sie auch
mitbekommen er wird hier ein Junge
vermisst und dann sagte die Mutter
sofort ja ja das ist der kleine See da
der ist hier weg ja das der hat hier mit
meinem Sohn gespielt und dann kam ein
junger Mann und hat den beiden Pokémon
Karten angeboten obwohl der Fall sehr
lange zurück liegt war damals auch schon
mal Pokémon go haben dann hinterher
ständige kann aber damals waren die
Pokémon Karten für Kinder total wertvoll
und er hat halt gesagt ich habe ganz
besondere tolle Karten die schenke ich
euch und sie sagte dann noch zum Glück
ist mein Sohn nicht mitgegangen ich habe
ihm das immer erklärt du gehst nie mit
Fremden mit und der kleine See das ist
leider mitgegangen jetzt hat mich
natürlich sofort elektrisiert ich habe
dann sofort die Polizei angerufen weil
mir klar war das ist eine ganz wichtige
Zeugin und die Polizei ist dann auch
sofort gekommen hat die Frau von Nomen
und wie es dann später herauskam war das
auch wirklich genau der Täter denn der
Tote in dem Koffer und später noch der
Kopf leider abgetrennt in einer
Plastiktüte gefunden in dem
Altkleidercontainer das war der kleine
See dat und der Täter Oliver ist war der
den vom Spielplatz gelockt hatte mit dem
Pokémon Karten und so bekam dieser Fall
auch den Begriff des Pokémon Mordes und
so ist der BILD-Reporter zum
Hinweisgeber geworden und zum Teil der
Ermittlung frank hat jetzt schon sehr
viel erzählt wir fassen das hier noch
mal kurz zusammen am 9 Januar war der
kleine See da hat verschwunden die älter
das neunjährigen verteilen schon kurz
darauf Plakate in der Siedlung am
nächsten Tag dem 10 januar wird in einem
Altkleidercontainer eine Leiche gefunden
aber noch fehlen der Kopf und genaue
Spuren zum Täter beides fügt sich durch
den Fund der am nächsten Tag gemacht
wird da entdeckt ein Passant einen
Koffer in einem Müllcontainer in dem
schließlich der Kopf eines Jungen
gefunden wird jetzt steht fest dass es
sich um Sedat handelt die Polizei hat
deshalb eine recht einfache Frage an die
Bevölkerung in Duisburg Homberg wer
kennt diesen Koffer wem gehört er die
ebenso einfache Antwort eines Herrn S
das muss der Koffer meines Sohnes Oliver
sein am 12 januar 2001 drei Tage nach
dem Verschwinden von Sedat fahren Beamte
zur Wohnung ist zu der Zeit 22-Jährigen
aushilfs Kochs Oliver es und nehmen ihn
fest er wohnt in der
Friedrich-Ebert-Straße nur ein paar
Steinwürfe vom Spielplatz entfernt an
dem sie dort entführt
in ersten Vernehmungen streitet Oliver s
noch alles ab verstrickt sich aber in
Widersprüche und gesteht schließlich
während der Mordfall also rasend schnell
aufgeklärt wird steht Duisburg noch
unter Schock die Beerdigung des Jungen
am 20 Januar wird zu einem dramatischen
Großereignis Bild schreibt damals
Pokémon Mord
1.000 Trauernde auf der Beerdigung des
kleinen Sedat der weiße Sarg war auf dem
Marktplatz von Rheinhausen aufgebaut
1000 Männer und Jungen standen in
dichten rein dahinter sie hielten Blumen
in den Händen türkische Frauen waren
nicht anwesend sie Trauer nach
islamischem Recht für sich
während der 15-minütigen Trauerfeier
brach sedals Vater sedatin a51
bewusstlos zusammen ein Notarzt
behandelte ihn danach schleppte sich der
Vater für ein letztes Gebet zum Grab
seines Sohnes die Kripo hat unter dessen
bald ein erstes Bild von dieser Tat es
gibt eine Leiche und eine Tatort nämlich
die Wohnung von Oliver s es gibt Spuren
und Beweismittel wie den Koffer an dem
sich sie dazu Kopf befand außerdem kann
ein Nachbars junge schildern wie sie das
von einem jungen Mann vom Spielplatz in
der Charlottenstraße weggelockt wurde es
war ja BILD-Reporter Frank Schneider der
die Mutter des kleinen zeigen getroffen
und befragt hatte aber die
Öffentlichkeit und die Eltern wissen
noch nicht wie krank und pervers der
Hintergrund des todesdrama war
der Strafprozess führt alle Beteiligten
an ihre Grenzen bevor wir den Ablauf der
tatprotokollieren gibt uns Frank
Schneider eine kompakte Zusammenfassung
ja der Richter hat damals auch gesagt
ein so schreckliches abartiges und
grausames Verbrechen hat er selten
erlebt und auch besonders dass das
Mordmotiv so was von unglaublich
schrecklich Hintergrund war das Oliver s
eine Freundin damals hatte und ähm
irgendwie waren noch sehr jung er war 23
die Freunde war 18 als sie dann später
vor Gericht stand und er hat dann
erzählt dass die beiden Fantasien
entwickelt hätten beim Sex mal ein Kind
dabei zu haben was ja schon absurd ohne
Ende ist und ähm das Kind auch
vielleicht tot sein soll also es war
absolut absurd und schreckliche hat das
aber relativ kühl auch geschildert vor
Gericht als wenn sie gar nichts angeht
und ja hat dann gesagt dass er den
Jungen weggelockt habe und dann hat er
eigentlich seine Freundin damit
überraschen wollen und eigentlich
wollten sie gemeinsam töten weil sie
auch mal sehen wollten wie das ist wenn
einer stirbt da der Junge sich aber gew
und wollte aus der Wohnung wieder raus
hat er Ina drosselt bevor die Freundin
da war und er erzählte dann sogar vor
Gericht dass die Freundin dann sauer war
als sie kam und er war schon tot sie
wollte doch dabei sein sie hat die Tat
immer bestritten ist aber auch
vorurteilt worden zur Beihilfe weil sie
bei der Tötung nicht dabei war sondern
nur bei der Schändung und Beseitigung
der Leiche und dann soll man Sex gehabt
haben und die Kinderleiche dabei das hat
aber dann nicht den Effekt gebracht in
die beiden sich versprochen hatten und
dann kommt ein Detail was ich bis heute
unbereiflich finde dann hat man die
kinderleicht hinter die Couch gelegt hat
ein Pizzataxi angerufen hat sich Pizza
liefern lassen Pizza gegessen hat dann
die leicht wieder hervorgeholt nachdem
er gegessen hatte und hatte überlegt was
können wir damit jetzt noch machen hat
dann im Badezimmer in der Dusche den
Kopf abgetrennt
und
beim Fund des Kopfes war dann für die
Polizei auch so schrecklich für die
Dozenten auch dass der Kopf die
Schneidezähne abgebrochen hatte oben wie
unten zur Vorgeschichte dieses absurden
und grausamen Mordes gehört also unter
anderem eine schräge Liebesbeziehung der
hagere rothaarige Oliver S und seine
etwas pummelige blonde Freundin Jessica
bilden eine Art Allianz der Sonderlinge
Oliver geht als schrulliger Einzelgänger
er hat durch eine Fehlbildung des
rückrats einen sehr deutlichen Buckel
mit 17 hat er sogar mal aushilfsweise
als Erzieher gearbeitet mittlerweile
jobt er in der Küche eine
Schnellrestaurants Jessica die fünf
Jahre jünger ist wächst als Adoptivkind
auf weil ihre Drogensüchtige Mutter auf
der Straße lebt das Liebespaar findet
den Gedanken erregend in Gegenwart eines
toten Kindes Sex zu haben der Prozess
gegen das mörderische paar beherrscht im
Frühsommer 2001 Schlagzeilen kann man
sich vorstellen und schon das Grundmotiv
an sich macht die Beteiligten
fassungslos laut Oliver es mordete das
Paar einfach aus purer Lust am Tod
anderer das hat Frank Schneider ja
gerade schon erzählt am Tag der Tat will
Oliver die Mord und Sexfantasie des
Paares endlich wahr machen er hatte
schon mehrfach zuvor versucht sie dazu
entführen aber der hatte sich stets
geweigert mitzukommen das ist spannend
warum sedert das fragt der Richter im
Prozess auch Olivers Antwort weil er so
nett aussah ich konnte ihn gut leiden am
9 januar 2001 versprichte ihm wertvolle
Pokémon Karten Sedat kommt mit vor der
Wohnung in der Friedrich-Ebert-Straße
zögert sie das einzutreten Oliver
schubst ihn hinein dann er wird er ihn
und von hier an gibt es gleich mehrere
Versionen des Ablaufs mal behauptet
Oliver er habe sie da zunächst in einen
Koffer gesteckt und diesen unter die
Schrank geschoben bis Jessica zu Besuch
kam denn er habe seine Freundin
überraschen wollen an andermal erzählt
er die Leiche habe offen herumgelegen
als Jessica kam und die beiden dann Sex
hatten
zwischenzeitlich beschuldigt er sie
sogar am erdrosseln des Kindes direkt
beteiligt gewesen zu sein Sedat habe
noch gezuckt und Jessica habe ihn
gewirkt bis Ruhe war jessica hingegen
versucht im Prozess ihre Unschuld dazu
legen Bild schildert damals einen
Verhandlungstag so Jessica kam mit Birne
und Butterbroten zum Prozess
ungeschminkt blaues Halstuch Jessica
über den mortag gegen 17 Uhr kam ich in
seine Wohnung es dauerte sehr lange bis
er mir aufmachte er war sehr nervös und
sehr anhänglich sogar wenn ich ins Bad
musste ging er mit wir haben Nudeln mit
Fertigsoße gegessen ferngesehen und
hatten Geschlechtsverkehr
nichts gar nichts habe sie von dem Kind
bemerkt dass zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon
erwirkt in der Wohnung lag Jessica
widerspricht damit den Geständnissen die
sie selber der Kripo gegenüber vorher
gemacht hatte den zufolge war sie an der
Planung der Tat beteiligt genauso wie
sie an der Beseitigung der Leiche
beteiligt war ein Prozess wird sie zur
Rede gestellt noch mal der Artikel aus
Bild vom 8 mai 2001 Staatsanwalt Martin
zu Jessica
mussten sie denn nicht kotzen als sie
die scheußlichen Einzelheiten erfuhren
Jessica schlecht war mir schon aber
übergeben musste ich mich nicht jetzt
ist Jessica wütend zum ersten Mal
spricht Sie Oliver direkt an ich finde
es ziemlich traurig dass du mich
belastest du kannst hier aufstehen und
die Wahrheit sagen dass ich es nicht
getan habe
Oliver murmelt dazu sage ich jetzt nicht
in diesem bildartikel wird auch deutlich
wie sehr der Prozess die Beteiligten
mitnimmt die Mutter Schlucht steht vor
dem Zusammenbruch der ermittelnde
Kommissar Ulrich wie weint mehrmals und
muss vom Richter getröstet werden
unerträglich diese Tat und damit auch
das Verfahren
wie Frank Schneider schon erwähnt hat
deutet der Zustand des Kopfes darauf hin
dass das perverse paar noch weitere
bizarre Dinge mit dem Körper des Opfers
vorhatte aber diese Details ersparen wir
uns lieber der Prozess sieht sich über
13 unerträgliche Verhandlungstage am 22
juli 2001 verkündet die Duisburger
jugendstraftkammer ihre Entscheidung
Oliver s wird zu 14 Jahren Haft
verurteilt und in die Psychiatrie
eingewiesen das Gericht stuft ihn wegen
seines Kranken geistigen Zustandes als
vermindert schuldfähig ein Jessicas
Argumentation geht tatsächlich teilweise
auf ihr kann keine direkte
tötungsbeteiligung nachgewiesen werden
eine mit Schuld gibt er das Gericht
wegen der Vorbereitung der Tat und der
Beseitigung der Leiche
Jessica bekommt sechseinhalb Jahre Haft
das heißt sie lebt längst wieder in
Freiheit
wildreporter Frank Schneider hat der
Fall den er zufällig auf dem Spielplatz
in Duisburg-Homberg mitlöste nie wieder
losgelassen besonders die Kälte dieser
monströsen Taten von Oliver s er sitzt
bis heute in der Psychiatrie in der
geschlossenen und ich glaube er wird
auch wirklich lebenslang dort bleiben
das ist eine der Fälle man hat ihn immer
wieder zwischendurch begutachtet das ist
steht ihm ja auch zu und er hat sagt
sein Anwalt auch mal bis heute
wenigstens ehrlich gesagt immer wieder
gesagt wenn er rauskommt sucht er sich
wieder ein Kind also das ist wirklich
einer der Fälle der einen so zurück
lässt wo man denkt was geht in so einem
Kopf eines solchen Täters vor in der
kamerose hatte schon immer auf Fotos die
Hälfte von Kindern durchgekratzt er
hatte die Schnürsenkel der Schuhe der
Freundin seiner Schwester
durchgeschnitten wenn sie zu besuchen
also immer schon Kranke Anwandlung wenn
ich an den Herne Killer denke auch der
ähnlicher Typ auch komische Außenseite
komischer Typ es sind immer wieder diese
Typen die Außenseiter sind die im Leben
nichts darstellen und es sind häufig das
Sagen Kriminalpsychologen sogenannte
Soziopathen die spüren keine Gefühle die
können keine Gefühle erleben die haben
keine Empathie die haben keinen Mitleid
kein Mitgefühl und deshalb können sie
auch so agieren und er hat auch damals
geschildert er wollte sogar in das
Gesicht schauen wenn er den Jungen tötet
er wollte sehen wie der ihn anguckt das
ist so schrecklich aber das ist auch in
der Vernehmung so gewesen die Kripo
Beamten haben gesagt das war
unerträglich wir das geschildert hat
komplett teilnahmslos ein Grippe hat sie
auch selber angezeigt weil er während
der Vernehmung den ohrfeigt hat den
Täter weil er das nicht ertrug wieder
darüber gesprochen hat wie wie eiskalt
aber die sind nicht eiskalt im Sinne von
kaltblütig sondern sie können das nicht
empfinden sie wissen auch nicht was sie
angerichtet haben
wir richten immer viel Aufmerksamkeit
auf die Täter weil wir versuchen die
Taten zu verstehen das ist auch in
Ordnung aber unser Mitgefühl muss
natürlich den Opfern und ihren Familien
gehören die all das ertragen müssen und
ihn gilt auch hier das Schlusswort und
Frank Schneider die Erde der Eltern von
Seelen ist daran zerbrochen an dem
Kummer und dem Leid der Vater hat einen
schweren Herzinfarkt erlitten er war nie
mehr arbeitsfähig und es ist häufig so
viel Leid was angerichtet wird gerade
wenn Kinder sterben weil die Familien
ihr Leben lang mit diesem Trauma nicht
fertig werden
[Musik]
das war Tatort Deutschland für heute
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Frank
Schneider Postproduktion durch record
Studios München wir hoffen ihr seid doch
bei der nächsten Folge wieder dabei euer
Mirko und euer Stefan